hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and life
today we are finally gonna be talking
about keyboards a lot of y'all watching
are probably gonna be software engineers
or aspiring software engineers or maybe
you just appreciate a good keyboard and
want to know what i think so whether
you're coding or studying or doing other
kinds of work or chatting or whatever
today i wanted to recommend my favorite
keyboards i'm actually going to be
listing a few of them because i don't
actually think there's like a perfect
keyboard that fits everybody's needs
because people like what they like and
our preferences are different but i'm
going to be covering my top favorite and
be talking about the pros and cons of
each i've been using each for about a
month or two some for like a year so i
feel like i have some pretty good like
developed thoughts about each keyboard
now that i wanted to share quick
disclaimer though i've been gifted three
of the four keyboards that i'm going to
be talking about so thank you to
logitech and kikron for doing so i
honestly probably would have bought them
in my own even if they hadn't gifted me
them but thank you also i should note
that my use of each keyboard has been
suited to my needs so i might not be
using like all of the features that are
listed of a keyboard so i recommend
checking out each of them i'll leave
links in the description box down below
so that you can look at the technical
specifications and see the capabilities
of each anyways shall we get started the
first keyboard is gonna come at no
surprise to anybody because it's the
logitech mx keys
i've talked about this in multiple
videos specifically a lot of my desk
setup related videos but it's a fan
favorite y'all so i actually have two of
these keyboards one is the regular mx
keys that has the windows layout but you
can also still use it for mac and then
this one specifically was designed for
mac this is the mx keys for mac and it
has the mac layout for the keyboard and
the color corresponds to the gray that
the macs come in i use the mac one
because i mostly do all of my work on a
mac computer and it's most similar to
the apple keyboard but i like this one
more because it has way more
functionality the mx keys can connect to
up to three devices using bluetooth or
the logitech unifying the receiver which
is great because i have multiple
computers one for work one for streaming
and one for personal use and so it's
nice to not have to switch between
multiple keyboards to use all three the
other thing that makes this keyboard
super powerful is the ability to program
specific keys to do different things
both at the system level and at the app
level so it's really useful if you have
common workflows for heavy duty apps i
use it for editing in premiere pro and
it's made my editing workflow just so
much faster it's actually most powerful
when you use the mx keys with the mx
master 3 mouse which i also use which
you can also program all the keys on
here as well also the fact that this
keyboard is wireless keeps my desk
looking clean and not cluttered i like
that it's a full layout keyboard as well
and it's not that bulky and it looks
super sleek on your desk as far as cons
go i don't actually think there's that
many cons like maybe a con is that the
keys aren't mechanical and they're kind
of like those like chiclet keys but i
feel like that's more of like a
stylistic thing than a con and the other
thing is that should you choose to
connect via bluetooth it can be a little
bit unreliable but i think that's more
the fault of the bluetooth technology
than the keyboard itself i also have the
wrist rest that corresponds to this
keyboard but do you really need it i
mean the profile of this thing is really
slim so i don't think it's completely
necessary but a nice to have
next on the list of standard keyboards
is my keychron keyboard
the model that i have is the k2 and i
chose the white backlight one because
rainbow colors are not really my vibe i
chose also to get the brown switches
over other ones because they tend to be
a little bit more quiet as you'll notice
this isn't like a full-size keyboard
it's got 84 keys i thought i would miss
the numpad more because i really like
full layout keyboards but
it's been fine without it honestly so
the things that i like about this
keyboard i mean it's a mechanical
keyboard it's just like super fun to
type on i'm really glad that i got the
brown switches because they're clicky
but not too loud so if you're sharing
your space with someone then these are
probably one of the quieter keys to get
i also really like that on the kikron
website for this product you can see
videos and hear the sounds of all the
different key switches that they offer
so you can choose the one that works for
you the other thing that i like that i
alluded to in my previous video is the
key cap set i got the retro mac layout
one and it's just so cute the colors are
really clean it looks great on my desk
this key cap right here says hello and
it's just cute i think it's also really
nice because it's just like an out of
the box mechanical keyboard that works
from the get-go the whole mechanical
keyboard world is like a pandora's box
to me and i'm afraid of opening it
because that means i'll spend so much
time and money on it and so this was
like a nice gentle intro that got me
into the world but it doesn't make me
hungry to buy like thousands of keycap
sets like i mentioned this is the k2 but
they have multiple kinds of kikron
keyboards and so you can find the size
and style that you like i also have the
wrist rest for this which it's just so
pretty i love this natural wood finish
the keyboard itself is a little bit
taller than something like the mx keys
and so being able to pair a wrist rest
with it make sure that my wrists don't
hurt after a full day of typing this
keyboard you can connect through a wired
connection with usbc or you can do
bluetooth which brings me to my cons the
major con of this keyboard is that the
bluetooth kind of sucks first of all the
keyboard kind of just goes to sleep
easily and so if i'm in a meeting or
something and i don't type for a while
then it takes kind of a long time for
the keyboard to reconnect to my mac i
want to say it takes like anywhere from
like 5 to 15 seconds to do so versus
something like the logitech mx keys
which is pretty immediate and this is a
tiny nitpick but you can tell that the
keyboard is connected via bluetooth
through the backlight indicator but if
you're using the keyboard in broad
daylight then it's kind of hard to tell
what's going on so that's just kind of
like a usability nitpick standpoint so i
kind of have to just like make a little
shadow with my hand to see what's going
on one of the things i was really
excited about in using the kikron is
that this thing can also connect to up
to three bluetooth devices but it's just
really hard to do so i think because the
response time in the bluetooth is like
not very good switching between two
devices just makes it even harder and so
because it takes such a long time and
you can't really tell what's going on
because of the backlight i find myself
switching between keyboards instead of
trying to use this thing for all my
devices so so long as i'm really only
using like one main computer heavily and
i'm willing to wait that 5 to 15 seconds
to connect to bluetooth it's otherwise a
very pleasant keyboard to use and it's
fun to use it
[Applause]
next we're going to talk about my two
favorite ergonomic keyboards and the
first one is again my logitech this is
the ergo k860
[Music]
so this one as you can tell is not a
split keyboard by any means but the keys
are actually split in half here if you
want to know the benefits of using an
ergonomic keyboard then i made a video
with my friend pat last year about
ergonomic desk setup so make sure to
check that out anyways i like this one
because this is like the first like
minimal cool not bulky looking ergonomic
keyboard since basically the microsoft
sculpt and i think i still like this one
more because this does a lot of the same
things that the logitech mx keys does in
that you can connect up to three devices
using bluetooth or the unifying receiver
it's wireless and the keys are
programmable the thing that i don't like
about it is that the build quality i
feel like is just okay the mx keys feels
a little bit more high quality honestly
this one just feels kind of like
plasticky i guess so i don't love using
it it's not like a great experience to
use it but it does really help with my
typing if my wrists are hurting and
because it has a lot of the same
features like the cons that i talked
about for the mx keys also apply to this
keyboard as well
and the last keyword i want to talk
about is a mechanical split ergonomic
keyboard and that is this one
goodness this one's just so much bulkier
than the other ones this is a kinesis
gaming freestyle edge split gaming
keyboard and i have the model kb 950.
this is the keyboard that i used during
my entire time at netflix and i bought
this one because wire cutter came out
with an article about the best ergonomic
keyboards and this was one of them for
the model that i got i got the blue
switches and it's not the rainbow one
it's just blue backlit which again
rainbow keyboards just not really my
vibe i guess the thing that i like the
most about this keyboard is that it's a
mechanical and split keyboard i feel
like those are kind of hard to come by
and hard to find i actually built my own
ergodox before which is also a
mechanical split keyboard but the layout
just took so long to get used to and my
hands were too small to use it
comfortably but this one is just a
really kind of natural
version of a keyboard except that it's
split and has mechanical keys this
keyboard comes with like a built-in
wrist rest that you can attach to the
bottom of the keyboard and you can set
it to be at whatever angle you want so
it's pretty customizable one of the
things that i don't like about this
keyboard is that it's wired which means
that the connection is super reliable
but it really clutters my desk because
there's a wire that connects these two
keyboards and then there's a wire that
connects the keyboard to the computer
and that's just like two more wires than
i want on my desktop the other con which
i think is really just more my mistake
is that i got the blue switches which
honestly are just like so dang loud and
i say it's my mistake because this thing
comes in different key switches and i
just happen to choose the blue one
when i was at netflix because this thing
was so clacky my co-workers all thought
i was like flexing my typing speed and
like smashing my keyboard when in fact i
was just typing normally it's just
really loud the last con which is kind
of more like a stylistic thing and kind
of a nitpick is that it's really bulky
it takes up a lot of space you can tell
that it's a gaming keyboard just because
of the backlit and the size of it all
and that's just not really my vibe but
functionally speaking i think this one's
really great
so those four are my favorite keyboards
if i had to recommend one of them to
everybody i think it would have to be
the logitech mx keys and i think it's
because it's kind of like a
one-size-fits-all solution sure it's not
ergonomic but there's no learning curve
to try to adapt to an ergonomic layout
and it's really familiar to the regular
apple keyboard but with just way more
functionality i think at the end of the
day it's my favorite keyboard but i am a
little bit addicted to mechanical
keyboards right now so i've been using
the keychron as my main i didn't start
out as like a keyboard enthusiast by any
means i use the apple keyboard like
everybody else and just because you have
a fancy keyboard doesn't mean that
you're like a better software engineer
or anything like that but it has been
fun to explore different keyboards and
try them out so i hope this was helpful
and opened your eyes to the different
keyboards out there and how fun typing
could be at the end of the day a good
keyboard is all based on personal
preference as long as all the keys work
and you can hit all the keys comfortably
and the keyboard itself is not going to
cause any discomfort it's probably okay
if there's any keyboards that i missed
or anything i should try out or any of
your favorite that i didn't talk about
then leave it in the comments down below
make sure to subscribe to my channel so
you can get notified about videos like
this one and more and i will see you
next time bye